in my video on the circle division
problem I referenced Euler's
characteristic formula and here I would
like to share a particularly nice proof
of this fact it's very different from
the inductive proof typically given but
I'm not trying to argue that this is
somehow better or easier to understand
than other proofs instead I chose this
topic to illustrate one example of the
incredible notion of duality and how it
can produce wonderfully elegant math
first let's go over what the theorem
states if you draw some dots and some
lines between them that is a graph and
if none of these lines intersect which
is to say you have a planar graph and if
your drawing is connected then Euler's
formula tells us that the number of dots
minus the number of lines plus the
number of regions these lines cut the
plane into including that outer region
will always be too because Euler was
originally talking about 3d polyhedron
when he found this formula which was
only later reframed in terms of planar
graphs
instead of saying dots we say vertices
instead of saying lines we say edges and
instead of saying regions we say faces
hence we write Euler's discovery as V
minus E Plus F equals two before
describing the proof I need to go
through three pieces of graph theory
terminology cycles spanning trees and
dual graphs if you are already familiar
with some of these topics and don't care
to see how I describe them feel free to
click the appropriate annotation and
skip ahead imagine a tiny preacher
sitting on one of the vertices let's
name him Randolph if we think of edges
as something Randolph might travel along
from one vertex to the next we can
sensibly talk about a path as being a
sequence of edges that Randolph can
travel along where we don't allow him to
backtrack on the same edge a cycle is
simply a path that ends on the same
vertex where it begins you might be able
to guess how cycles will be important
for our purposes since they will always
enclose a set of faces
now imagine that Randolph wants access
to all other vertices but edges are
expensive so he'll only buy access to an
edge if it gives them a path to an
untouched vertex this frugality will
leave him with a set of
Edge's without any cycles since the edge
finishing off a cycle would always be
unnecessary in general a connected graph
without cycles is called a tree so named
because we can move things around and
make it look like a system of branches
and any tree inside a graph which
touches all the vertices is called a
spanning tree before defining the dual
graph which runs the risk of being
confusing it's important to remember why
people actually care about graphs in the
first place
I was actually lying earlier when I said
a graph is a set of dots and lines
really it's a set of anything with any
notion of connection but we typically
represent those things with dots and
those connections with lines for
instance facebook stores and enormous
graph where vertices are accounts and
edges are friendships although we could
use drawings to represent this graph the
graph itself is the abstract set of
accounts and friendships completely
distinct from the drawing all sorts of
things are undrawn graphs the set of
English words considered connected when
they differ by one letter mathematicians
considered connected if they've written
a paper together neurons connected by
synapses or maybe for those of us
reasoning about the actual drawing of a
graph on the plane we can take the set
of faces this graph cuts the plane in
two and consider two of them connected
if they share an edge in other words if
you can draw a graph on the plane
without intersecting edges you
automatically get a second as of yet
undrawn graph whose vertices are the
faces and whose edges are well edges of
the original graph we call this the dual
of the original graph if you want to
represent the dual graph with dots and
lines first blue dot inside each one of
the faces I personally like to visualize
the dot for that outer region as being a
point somewhere at infinity where you
can travel in any direction to get there
next connect these new dots with new
lines that pass through the Centers of
the old lines where lines connected to
the point and infinity can go off the
screen in any direction as long as it's
understood that they all meet up at the
same one point
but keep in mind this is just the
drawing of the dual graph just like the
representation of Facebook accounts and
friendships with dots and lines is just
a drawing of the social graph the dual
graph itself is the collection of faces
and edges the reason I stress this point
is to emphasize that edges of the
original graph and edges of the dual
graph are not just related they're the
same thing
you see what makes the dual graph all
kinds of awesome is the many ways that
it relates to the original graph for
example cycles in the original graph
correspond to connected components of
the dual graph and likewise cycles in
the dual graph correspond with connected
components in the original graph now for
the cool part suppose our friend
Randolph has an alter-ego Mortimer
living in the dual graph traveling from
face to face instead of from vertex to
vertex passing over edges as he does so
let's say Randolph has bought all the
edges of a spanning tree and that
Mortimer is forbidden from crossing
those edges it turns out the edges that
Mortimer has available to him are
guaranteed to form a spanning tree of
the dual graph to see why we only need
to check the two defining properties of
spanning trees they must give Mortimer
access to all faces and there can be no
cycles the reason he still has access to
all faces is that it would take a cycle
in Randolph spanning tree to insulate
him from a face but trees cannot have
cycles the reason mortimer cannot
reverse a cycle in the dual graph feels
completely symmetric if he could he
would separate one set of Randolph's
vertices from the rest
so the spanning tree from which he is
banned could not have spanned the whole
graph so not only does a planar graph
have a dual graph any spanning tree
within that graph always has a dual
spanning tree in the dual graph here's
the kicker the number of vertices in any
tree is always 1 more than the number of
edges
to see this note that after you start
with the root vertex each new edge gives
exactly one new vertex alternatively
within our narrative you could think of
Randolph as starting with one vertex and
gaining exactly one more for each edge
that he buys in what will become a
spanning tree since this tree covers all
vertices in our graph the number of
vertices is 1 more than the number of
edges owned by Randolph moreover since
the remaining edges make up a spanning
tree for Mortimer's dual graph the
number of edges he gets is 1 more than
the number of vertices in the dual graph
which are faces of the original graph
putting this together it means the total
number of edges is 2 more than the
number of vertices plus the number of
faces which is exactly what others
formula states